well welcome back to the morning toast I
am so excited about today's guest and
I'm gonna intro we are sitting down with
the iconic author of luckiest girl alive
Jessica Knoll is here you're also like a
movie producer now I don't even know how
to how to properly introduce you I know
I wear several hats
um I'm an executive producer I'm a
screenwriter novelist sometimes I write
essays for a little known place the New
York Times you know find me anywhere
honestly I wanted to introduce you
before we got in I have to tell you that
so up until the end of 2020 I had not
read a full book perhaps ever in my life
like I just did not like reading and I
did really judge other people who read
for fun I'm like oh my god get a life
um and then we went on vacation or like
are you are you lying like like I don't
know I believe you you know no no no no
no no not lying like and I don't think
she ever did the school reading I really
can't maybe back in the day you read
like no I'm a girl I'm saying I'm saying
like when people say I read for fun like
were you kind of like yeah you're lying
I don't believe you yeah I'm sure you do
read for fun have you ever had alcohol
like I was just I was a hater I was a
big time hater and December of 2020 we
went on vacation Jackie brought a hard
copy of luckiest girl alive and she
finished it and she was like she had
been trying to get me to read and she
was like Claudia just read this one book
and just read and just trust me and I
was like okay you know what what else am
I doing we're in the mountains I read
the entire book and since then I've read
over a hundred books like I'm obsessed
with reading now dead it all started
with luckiest girl alive and I'm not
even lying no lie oh my God that's
actually incredible my book was like a
gateway drug to reading yes like that it
was a gateway drug
that no one's ever told me that before
that makes me really really happy
I figured that you should know like the
work you do is so important
oh thank you
so you are the author of course of
luckiest girl alive which just got made
into a movie on Netflix which we're
going to talk about because that's so
major
um but I feel like before that you were
having this unprecedented success with
your book I mean we're obsessed with it
um can you talk a little bit about like
what the process was like from just you
know a girl with a book to then like a
best-selling on every list what was that
like
yeah
um that part of it once it once the book
was out in the world like that part of
it happened like in a pretty contained
space like about a year
um writing the book I for years like I'd
been a magazine editor so I was writing
this book while I was uh working at
Cosmopolitan so I would wake up in the
morning before work get like an hour to
an hour and a half of writing done and
then I would go into the office and I
wrote my book in like under a year uh
doing it that way and um my and you know
I had been fortunate enough that in my
very first shop out of college I had
briefly and disastrously worked as an
assistant to an agent at the Paradigm
Agency but what ended up happening is I
I met another assistant there who's who
was like this is actually what I want to
do be a literary agent so I left to work
in magazines and to write and she stayed
on and at the time she was promote voted
to like a junior agent like we were like
probably like 27. she emailed me and was
like you're writing so much for Cosmo
like I know you have a book in you like
you should write a book and then like
I'll sell it and like you know she
needed clients like you know she had
like just been kind of anointed as a
junior agent and um she also happened to
be from the same area I'm from outside
of Philadelphia we didn't know each
other in high school but like we were
only a year apart in age like it just
she got the kind of Malou of that area
which is like super specific so it was
also really great to like work with her
for that reason and then yeah she was
able to sell it you know I had that
connection I think working in magazines
at the time it was like I mean still I
think like Publishers love like magazine
editors because you tend to just be like
you know know a lot of people who could
potentially support the book and help
sell the book
um so I started writing the book in 2013
it published in 2015 and yeah all the
success came you know pretty quickly
that year of 2015 it was the
best-selling debut uh that year
yeah
that's like not normal like your first
book gets made into a Netflix movie like
that's not normal
no it's not normal and like it almost
didn't happen a lot of time like many
times I mean that was 2015 this book
came out and we're sitting here in the
fall of 2022 and you know with the movie
on the horizon so um yeah it took I've
been with this story for almost 10 years
which is crazy wow wow I feel like so
many of the books that we love that we
hear are going to be turned into movies
or shows actually don't wind up making
it all the way so the fact that the
movie is here now Claudia and I got to
watch a sneak we got a preview of it
screeners
uh which was one of the highlights of
our year for sure we really don't get
screeners for anything and if it was
going to be anything our favorite book
will do that's amazing
what was the process of making this into
a movie and I have to imagine anytime I
read a book I cast the movie in my head
it's like a fun way to use my brain and
I have to imagine when you're writing it
and even when it was going into a movie
production that you had someone in your
head was it always Mila Kunis and how
did she come to the role eventually
so at the time that I was writing the
book I really truly could not see past
like I just want this to be like
published as a book and I want it to
like do really well
um once the conversation started
happening around optioning it for a film
like that's when I was like oh you know
starting to think like that the thing
that's so that I just learned over the
last seven years and not just working on
this adaptation like I you know my
second book I'm working on adapting into
a TV show like I've written original
screenplays I've adapted other people's
books into screenplays now and so it's
it's like I'm like I'm tainted by like
the studio like suits you know because
like there's this idea of like this is a
bankable star you know people want to
watch this person like the studio will
sign off on this person then you have to
also you know have producer approval
director approval like they're so it's
so rare that like in who you picture in
your head and what you want
um is ever going to work out for
whatever reason that like I feel like I
don't even I don't even dream anymore
right because I'm just so like I just
have so I I just in my head I'm like so
practical about it now and so the Mila
of it was really interesting because we
had been set up at Lion at the Lionsgate
Studio out for years and they were
really interested in it initially and
then it they just couldn't get it off
the ground and they would only make it
with like two actresses and we were like
we're never gonna get them because
they're like crazy busy and booked up
for years and they're like well No One's
Gonna like want to come to a theater to
like see like you know all this you know
sensitive material which was always so
weird to me because I'm like but there's
like humor and a reverence in this and
like it's almost like a really
compelling intriguing story so like they
were just hyper focused on the more
traumatic elements of the book
um
so when we got to Netflix it was 2019
and Scott stuber who's the head of the
film department there was like the first
person we want you to go out to is Mila
Kunis and my reaction was actually I was
annoyed because the whole point of going
to Netflix was that we would have
flexibility in terms of the star we
could go out to and we had just I had
just been on this hamster wheel for
years of going out to big name stars and
having having them say no like they're
like this is just too like it's just too
tricky I'm just too scared to kind of
touch it and I was like we're just
wasting time like I thought if we came
to Netflix like we would just be able to
like we would have like a longer list of
names we could go out to like they
wouldn't have to be these big megawatt
stars and I was like she's just gonna
take forever to read and then she's just
gonna say no and then we're gonna lose
momentum and like this is exactly what
happened at Lionsgate and so I was like
really really annoyed and then she read
it and was like I'm into this guys like
let's talk and so I had to eat my words
because it like ended up being the best
thing ever no and she was amazing we've
seen the movie she was incredible I have
to imagine
um like any book to an author is deeply
personal but I read in your
acknowledgments that you know there were
parts of Tiffany's story that were true
to you so I imagine like handing that
over to a Lionsgate or Netflix can be
quite
um uncomfortable honestly because it's
your story being told by someone else
through someone else's eyes so you said
that you weren't executive producer is
that right
yeah that's right
so you were able to control it a little
bit more
yeah I mean I think it was the fact that
I was also the writer it's I I think
that executive producer is almost a
little bit of a vanity title for some
people some people it's not some people
you're actually doing the executive
producer work
um and sometimes if you're the author of
the IP of the original material but
you're not involved in the adaptation
they'll give you producer maybe not
executive but like or maybe they do I
don't I don't I shouldn't actually speak
on this like I know but normally you've
got some sort of producerial credit
um and and yes like Consulting like
they'll show you drafts but like if you
don't like something they're not gonna
like change it yeah like that was partly
why I was like I have to be the one to
adopt this myself even though I've never
written a screenplay before because I
the idea of not being involved every
step of the way and like knowing what
was going on like it just would have
made me bananas crazy like I'm crazy
control freak
um so it was like that as much a at the
time that that the story was being
handed over I hadn't really been vocal
about the fact that there was a lot of
me and my own experience in this
character so I think it was also me
trying to be super protective of like my
my own self and my own story
um so I was like no I need to be like
involved in everything yeah yeah
so when you adapt a um a book into a
movie overall like when was the first
day on set
the first day on set was June something
of 2021 so we have post-production yeah
so we had post-production it was about a
uh four months overall which includes
posts or sorry no I'm saying post
includes pre-production so that
pre-production's about like a month so
you're not filming for that whole time
um and you get weekends off or like
whatever our weekends happen to be
Saturday and Sunday but sometimes your
weekends are like Monday and Tuesday it
just depends what your film schedule is
um so yeah it was like a Monday sometime
in June I'm sure I can get the exact
date
um and we started with all the
flashbacks so Mila actually wasn't even
in on set at that point it was just all
the I call them kids but they're between
they're all over 18.
um right all the kids in the flat
they're kids to me yeah and the actress
who played young Mila was incredible
and that's like a human being she's just
like an incredible person too
so how do you decide because like the
book was it was a pretty long book how
do you decide what makes the cut for a
film and what doesn't like how do you
decide what is integral to the storyline
yeah it's interesting because it's like
there are things that we've taken out
put back in that we've added that aren't
in the book like it was con it was like
a constantly evolving kind of document
like I probably wrote close to 60 drafts
of that script over the years
um and and it's you know you always hear
people say that like film is much more
collaborative than a book and it truly
is and you with a book like it's really
just kind of you and your editor and
it's very hands off in a lot of ways
um in a movie there's so much more money
at stake and so you have so many more
people who have to weigh in and give
their opinion from all the producers to
your director to your Executives at
whatever your studio is so
a lot of times there would even be like
conflict or you know some people feeling
like I want this or I want to lose this
um so I just did my best to like I you
know I fought for what I really wanted I
I seeded some battles
um because I'm like maybe I wouldn't
have made that choice as like a
Storyteller but this person who knows
this medium has been doing this for
years and years and years is telling me
this is the right decision and giving me
a really good argument as to why so I'm
gonna and I I trust everyone I'm working
with so I'm gonna trust them that this
is the right decision and like there was
an example in particular where I fought
really hard for something and in the end
our director was like I'm gonna take
this out and I want you to see a cut of
the film without these two scenes in it
and he showed it to me and I was like
damn it yeah you're right you know yeah
I love the movie because I think it's so
similar to the book I feel like that
really doesn't happen so often there are
always so many changes or story lines
that have to be left out and I feel like
aside from like a few things
it's really how I Envision the book even
the people Mila Kunis like she's Ani
through Luke Luke was perfectly cast
yeah Luke was perfect is so good he's so
good also the settings were so wonderful
and I feel like the production value
even the fact that it was based in New
York I feel like so much stuff that's
based in New York isn't actually filmed
here but these are City street City
scenes and it really they filmed outside
our building remember yeah they did they
first saw those pictures of Mila and um
Luke walking down the street yeah like
that's so crazy
yeah we were dying we were so excited
and it really felt like the book come to
life so I imagine you must be you must
love the movie yeah right yes I love it
I mean I've seen it oh my God I've seen
it so many times and I've seen it
through so many iterations you know like
the first cut was really really rough
and I you know this is my first rodeo
with you know being involved in like
I've been in the develop process for a
lot of things but I've never gotten to
production I've never gotten to post I
had no idea post was going to be as much
work as it was which we were based out
of New York for that I was back and
forth I live in LA now but I was like
back and forth to New York a lot over
the winter
um and I couldn't believe how much
writing and rewriting I was doing
because they're recording stuff in ADR
sessions and kind of like slipping it in
like all that movie Magic
um but yes it was absolutely it was
beautifully lit which is like and all
the actors who were on set were like
this is so that I have to give credit to
our DP Colin watkinson for that because
like
he did all of that lighting and all of
those camera angles and like worked with
our director very closely to like pull
that off and the color palette and all
of that and like some of the extras
would even come off set and be like this
is the most like beautifully lit
production I've ever been on and I was
like wow oh my God that's amazing you
know it's like I learned all these
things that are like important to people
in front of the camera that like as
someone behind the camera like I never
would have even thought of on my own so
yeah it was a very like educational
experience for me too
yeah it was stunning I particularly love
the Nantucket scenes that home that
country home I just I need one of those
yes I need one of those too
um can I ask you a question like from
the book because am I toxic because I
like would have taken a bullet for Ani
and Mr Larson like they needed to get
together and I think there's like a
group of us who like ship them so hard
um and like what about an alternate
ending where they end up together they
end up together well it's so funny
because like agree like hard agree okay
okay and
like that's why I wrote that
um yeah I I it's so funny because when I
was writing the book I got to the point
where like they were back on the main
line for filming of the documentary and
they had done everything and they were
like you know getting really close
because they're like having these really
intimate conversations and then I was
like okay now they're gonna have sex and
so I like would sit down and I would try
and write them having sex and I couldn't
like everything I wrote felt so wooden
no one to blame but myself
um I consulted my my agent Alyssa and I
was like I can't write the scene and she
was like what if they don't actually
sleep together like what if it's just a
kiss and then when I went in to write
the chapter with that in mind it just
like flowed so easily yeah so there was
something about it where like and Alyssa
was always saying she was like look for
some people she's gonna be such a tough
pill to swallow the character herself
that you don't want to like add to that
you don't want to add another barrier to
for some people some people are like
look I get she's a [ __ ] I get it I'm on
board you know and like that's how I am
like she just doesn't bug me but there
you want a lot of people to read it so
it's like how many readers are you gonna
potentially lose because you're like
okay I don't like all these other things
she's said and done and now she's you
know screwing a married man
um right so I think it was better all
around in the end that they don't sleep
together and it's always a little hotter
when there's like that tension right
it's like yes and he was you know at one
point her teacher so like even though he
was a really young hot cool teacher I
guess it probably was for the best but I
just wanted you to know like there is a
community of us who ship yeah
I get it and it's like it's that you
know I I was actually talking to one of
our producers on the movie and like we
were just saying like
you know we need to like work on like an
erotic Thriller together like I need to
write something I'll read it because
it's like yeah it's just like right like
it's just when it things are wrong they
feel so right you know like it's like
what is what is that like it's all
anything give me anything toxic like I'm
just like shows me how far I have to go
in therapy because I'm like I'm I'm into
it 100 I will be first in line to read
that
so movie is out people are loving it
you're kind of like the toast of the
literary world the toast
um and you just came right before this
from doing the Kelly Clarkson show and
we are yeah Head Over Heels obsessed
with Kelly Clarkson like please tell us
about her
she so everyone told me they were like
Cali is legitimately like the coolest
most down to earth person like you'll
ever meet
um and I try the people who were telling
me this like I trusted them because
they're also people who have like warned
me in advance of like this person may
not be exactly what you're expecting
um so I've had those encounters too so
when these people are telling me she's
actually really amazing I was like I
know she will be
she is she's not intimidating at all
she's so easy to talk to
um she's just like a girl you want to
like go get like margaritas with like
she's really really cool a dream
margaritas with Kelly I need can you
imagine a better date
um so yeah and they sent us home with
these amazing gift bags that had this
has a bottle of red and then these
specialty chips that they're like the
only chip that is made to be had with
wine I never heard of this before and
there's one Kelly one one is manchego
flavored and one is smoke gouda and I'm
like this is this is the best gift bag
anyone has ever sent me home with
um Kelly is so classy She's So Close
she's so classy yeah so tell us we're
gonna be like first people in line for
your next book can you give like the
peeps a little update on that because I
follow you on Instagram it's been a
journey it's been a journey it's been a
journey um my God so my next book is we
don't have an exact publication date but
it's going to be summer 2023
and um it is a it's fiction but it is
based on a real life crime I feel like I
should just say it like this will be
like the first time I'm like talking
about it publicly but I think I should
just say it like what else am I gonna
get the opportunity
um so uh
Ted Bundy who I'm sure you guys know who
Tim buddy is okay
um so Ted bunnies and notorious serial
killer who operated in the 1970s and for
I I always knew who he was like you know
by name I I knew he was like the Seattle
killer and he was like handsome and
smart and like charismatic and all these
things
um
a couple years ago there was a new
documentary that was out about him and I
just noticed his conversation happening
on Twitter
um that was like why are we getting like
another documentary about him like don't
we already know everything there is to
know about him like what about like the
what you know he's he you know murdered
over 35 mil I mean in some in some
estimates like it could be as many as
100 women and um they're like we don't
know anything about these women so I
thought that was interesting and I
started just like doing a little
research I was like I wonder if there's
anything there and I just found a whole
new angle of this story that I was like
I've not seen this covered anywhere like
I did not know that his his final spree
happened in Florida where he entered the
sorority house at Florida State
University and attacked four girls in 15
minutes left two of them dead and that
the surviving women and the women who
lived in this sorority a had to go on to
be deposed by him because he was acting
Pro Se as his own attorney this was like
legal they had to be like they had to
like face him down and these are women
like in their early 60s like this didn't
happen like that that long ago you know
and the way they were treated and kind
of mistreated and there was so much
sexism and so much misinformation about
how brilliant he was he was not I was
amazed he was like a law school dropout
like he had terrible l-stat scores like
all this stuff the way he was like
memorialized and remembered it's so not
true and these women were actually
really the exceptional ones so it's a
kind of a fictional retelling
um from the perspective of one of the
sorority girls who's uh not a real
person but like just inspired in general
by like some of these women I read about
and then also from a woman who
ultimately becomes his victim back in
Seattle and there's kind of like a
character that goes between these two
um story lines and is kind of helping
bring him to Justice and there's also a
lot of mystery around some of the crime
still in Seattle
um like answers that you know so I I
kind of imagine what some of these
answers are that people never get so
there's still like uh you know you're
kind of pulling at a thread right you're
out what what happened
um so it's and it's it's it's a cool you
know it's Florida that part of Florida
is really cool and like a Gothic part of
Florida I don't like do you guys know
Florida very well because I I just moved
here you're like oh no wait you live in
Florida she just moved like two months
ago
the Panhandle which is like the northern
part of Florida it's very old Gothic
South like it's almost like you're in
like not like if the saying about
Florida which I think is so interesting
is the further south you go the more
North you get and then the more North
you go the further south you get because
North is like Miami and it's like super
Cosmopolitan and then when you're up in
kind of Northern Panhandle area it's
really that like old old southern
um like gorgeous oak trees and all of
that so I also had
um it was very intriguing to me to like
learn about this area and like do
research there and all of that it was
like a great setting
um like very rich setting for my next
book
um so we will love a rich setting we do
and I love the people are you able to
call him Ted Bundy in the book or do you
have to oh so that's the other thing
well I did it on my own because what I
what I read was when I I pulled all the
archives from um I pulled all the
transcripts from the Florida archives of
the depositions of the you know the
trial transcripts and what I found so
[ __ ] awesome was that he is recorded
in the records as the defendant and all
he ever wanted to be known as was a
lawyer an attorney like he never
completed law school like he couldn't he
wasn't a good law student he wasn't
smart
um he was just given the benefit of the
doubt because he was like kind of a
normal looking guy right and all these
women who raised the alarm about him
like were just not really believed and
um
so he's he is in these transcripts he's
acting as the attorney but he's not
given a name he's just called the
defendant because that's actually what
he is so I refer to him in my book as
the defendant
got it well I loved like that
perspective on the the reason for this
new book because Jackie and I were just
having this conversation on the podcast
last week where like as a culture we've
gotten to this extremely bizarre place
where we like romanticize these male
serial killers and we make a million TV
shows about them and in every show
they're hotter and cooler and more Suave
than the next and it's like you're not
really getting a nuanced POV about like
the actual horrendous acts of crime that
these people committed and they're
almost like becoming celebrities in a
weird way yes again that's what happened
again he was like yeah and also that
like the victims are just lost in this
telling like who are they what like I
think just like humanizing them and not
always showing like the violence they're
only shown to to show that they're like
the violence that's shown against them
right these were women that had like Big
Dreams big goals like some of them went
on to do amazing things with their lives
of others were like right at that like
that most exciting period in your life
like just you know a lot of them were
college students you know and like about
to take their final exams and like they
had big plans and they were like really
like some of these girls I was like
reading about and I interviewed some of
the sorority girls and I'm like these
were like cool fun girls you know and
like history has just completely
forgotten about them and swept them
aside and like they're just like the
victims you know
um so true I just
yeah so I think I just think this is
like just a different it's a reimagining
and it's just from a point of view of
it's I keep calling it it's everything
you don't know about the story that you
think you do because I really thought I
knew this story and then I did my
research and I was like this is even
crazier than I ever imagined and like
I'm so intrigued and com like all of
this is so compelling to me like I have
to find a way to like make this into a
book so that's number three baby
that sounds very so good
um thank you so much for being here like
this has truly been an honor I don't
think we've ever had an author except
for me yeah
um but thank you so much for being here
and thank you for the work that you've
done because honestly I actually the two
of you this is a thank you to Jackie and
to Jessica because Jackie finally got me
hooked on reading and it was you were
the vehicle your book
um so it's really been an honor to talk
to you congrats on all the success with
the movie and the book I mean it's not
shocking you're so talented and it's
really been an honor to have you on the
show for real thank you so much
thank you this has been so much fun
thank you for having me
you're so welcome and everyone go check
out luckiest girl live on Netflix but I
would recommend reading the book first I
think you should do both that's always a
favorite activity and you can compare
and contrast
you're here we'll see you on the next
one bye